[Music]
[Applause]
you're good don't you worry about it how
are you doing what's in here oatmeal or
no no no no that is water awesome i
think the impression you don't do a lot
of these real shows very oh definitely
not you do your show which is which is
hilarious i really and and uh and your
sidekick is hannibal burris who has
performed here he's fantastic he's
fantastic uh how are you doing how's
life sibilance uh life is good i feel
sick i feel like awful i just i finally
saw that movie precious in 3d at the
imax
she's something precious in 3d and i ate
like a ton of mushrooms
i didn't
really incredible not a lot of people
know this did you know that gabriele
sidibe and monique were both played by
eddie murphy in that movie
wow
yeah wow
it's actually the prequel to the clumps
i didn't realize that yeah these are
fantastic facts these are incredible
thanks man jimmy vevino hit me
two times
three times
100 times
[Applause]
and to be honest i don't think they can
count that yeah
la bomba gets lost after 40. uh
let's talk about you are you drinking
extra waters do you need more water you
can have mine if you want um that's not
water there's a bunch of bourbon in
there
you have an interesting background eric
your mom is jewish
your mom is jewish and your dad is
haitian yeah i'm bluish i'm black and
jewish black andrew
my uh my dad looks like arthur ashe and
my mom looks like howard stern
my dad that is hot
no wonder they came together
my dad is he's from haiti he's old
school he's like in his 60s he's
completely technologically illiterate in
80d he just found out what google is
and he called me up and he goes oh oh
now they have google whoo
you type one word in google bloop bloop
one million words comes
whenever he loses his weight
conversation under the sea
uh you know you should be i don't know
if they're proud of this or not your
photo the new york times ran a story on
you and this was the photo that ran of
you in the new york times
yeah ladies question mark this explain
the context young men questioner
we did a nude cooking segment and uh we
were cooking and a bunch of like sausage
grease was splashing up on my junk yeah
and uh my dad was like oh he saw the
picture he was like they should change
your costume in that picture they should
change i was like well it's not a
costume it's a lack of a costume
and uh i don't know how to change a
picture that's already been printed a
million times
uh is that technology out there he
thought your nude body was a costume
i don't know how to explain imagine i
don't know uh you do uh very funny did
we start yet are we on no no this is all
just the practice okay actually we're
gonna do the real thing in like six
weeks okay excellent awesome these
people all work for me oh fantastic
you do a lot of what's with the feet on
the front sorry i'm sorry i don't know
should i take my shoes off no no please
don't get your feet back up i like your
feet
i want you to relax okay great
ridiculous
absurd
yeah oh that's helped your hair a lot
yeah
shirts off guys shirts off how about it
sure no no no no i would blow out every
monitor in this country
the contrast between the air around me
and my skin
would destroy televisions